puisque c'est du rock c'est un toc toc
toc spécial rock ces parties qui est là
toc toc toc qui est l' elysée c qui gène
j gc qui j'ai demandé à la lune
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bella
moi
magath a dit merci
[Applaudissements]
alors sachez le frédéric ce n'est pas
lui qui est amour at elle qui était
amoureuse de moi je sais pas lui c'est
pas lui c'est pas benjamin castaldi
voilà vous êtes déçu non non non
attention voici le deuxième c'est parti
toc toc toc qu'un hervé
[Applaudissements]
maxime
vanté pour le milieu autochtone clan
catch tact et pmp toc toc toc et merci
d'être là les chéris je vous fais des
gros gros bisous chez que cebu les
vacances pour certains est très bien
pour l'instant les costumes sont
vraiment top
non franchement et benji vous savez que
le brun très bien comme ça t'as qu'à
chaque fois qu'on est ridicule il trouve
ça bien mais vraiment sans rigoler mary
que c'est moi à 20 ans ouais mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya quelque chose oui on a les
mêmes oreilles regarder ça vous va bien
alors attention croit le chanteur toc
toc c'est parti
[Musique]
sable
visa
[Applaudissements]
alors et cette fois peur c'est pas
possible c'est vrai j'ai évité
merci merci des films sans mal quand
même c'est pas un jeu 38 ans l'enfant
s'est pas et cabrol de vous non mes
cheveux trempés dans l'encré c'est pas
mal malheureusement c'est pas être
pathos you say party
l'avez vous imaginez déjà l'angoissé
vous êtes chez votre voisin et patata
mais kiryienka vient de passer du sel tu
dis c'est faites entrer l'accusé
tu tu prends tu prends une arme vas-y
alors fait tacatac gilles dutilh j'ai
loué jiwei ou en fuite
[Applaudissements]
g
et ça rigolait il a le haut de freddie
mercury et le banc dira cuistot il va
nous faire des frites
attention attention les cherry pour chat
d'oc toc toc c'est parti et c est là pas
du toc toc toc toc toc qui est là
arlette arletty allait-il dire les tibi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
témoin ça on arrête tout la gn et où il
a eu un cauchemar je l'attendais alors
vous avez compris qui construit vous
connaissiez non non quoi il ya eu un
coup de foudre on s'est croisé ya très
longtemps au bac à sable
non mais ça arrive et vous êtes tarmac
direct je sais pas mais il a dû tomber
chez moi j'ai senti ça comme ça vous
savez c'est les choses ça s'explique pas
ça des données moi j'ai vu alors moi ce
que je propose c'est que vous vous
retrouviez vous fassiez un petit sous
tous les deux ah oui parce que de
situations intimes au litige attention
et je vais vous chanter une chanson
attention maintenant permettez vous de
la nation et après si vous avez envie de
vous embrasser
c'est à vous de voir où vous embrasser
ou vous partez chacun de votre côté a
tôt fait c'est pas moi je n'étais rien
et moi pour lui je suis le gardien du
sommeil de ses nuits je lève à mourir
blindés ont tous pouvaient détruire tout
ce qu'il vous plaira pour tout
reconstruire pour tout reconstruire
en fait je vais jouer et dès que
j'arrêterai je dirais scop ce match
alors on fait comme les chaises
musicales mois l'a fait je fais une
chanson en anglais comme ça l'a fait
vois tu ce mac
[Applaudissements]
non mais là c'est parti
c6 et c5 un malaise je kiffe a laissé
balle et ma maman maman danielle su nous
regardent tout se passe bien
ouais elle aime beaucoup federico si
lara fabian d'auray et voilà si vous
sentez quelque chose frédéric c'est pas
votre portable
attention c'est reparti une autre chose
ou sur mac
ça s'est arrêté pendant qu'on reprend
nord fait l'autre au point des
allochtones
[Applaudissements]
les
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
alors frédéric juste franchement il ya
des mots c'est parce que vous allez vous
revoir mais j'espère déjà les ont
invités chez moi non mais alors les
séries est ce que vous voulez aller
dîner ce soir
moi je veux bien daniel way sans rigoler
mais les mecs qui se passe un truc de
ouf la énorme et on a faim il ne connaît
pas mais on a plein de comminges et on
s'est croisé tout à l'heure et cinq
minutes dans les coulisses il ya eu 1
et voilà c'est un jour dire c'est le
principe de l'appareil photo le
flashback non mais franchement vous
savez que je suis choqué non vous n'êtes
pas choquer vous êtes frappé l'étrangeté
mais j'suis est franchement s est pas
beau ce qui s'est passé ça me rappelle
benjamin castaldi
[Rires]
je vous invite à la nouvelle eve le 30
et le soir ce soir alors est-ce que vous
allez passer une soirée ensemble d'abord
écouté je peux pas parler il ya trop de
monde
est-ce qui est ce que vous êtes vous
êtes commence à avoir un début de damour
ah ben moi c'était vraiment il ya un
truc qui s'est passé j'ai senti que
c'était moins dans leur ego et vous vous
avez commencé à avoir un début de
direction
quand j'étais petit je croyais que
c'était un os déjà d'accord est en tout
cas très content que l'amour en sortent
grandis
oui on a raté qu'un mariage ici ces
fatwas
alors faut-il le tract à quatre
cylindres à l'oncfs là franchement
isabelle mais tu crois que c'est un truc
nous parce que là et regarde quand il se
regarde et qu'on se fait des clins
d'oeil il m'a dit qu'on va changer de
place à y aller sur place
allez-y et bras d'or prenait la place de
matthieu delormeau c'est votre fils de
mecs vous savez j'ai pas de style bois
il faut qu'il ya un truc un feeling
il était proche de sa maman j'ai eu
plein nuage et le säntis plein de signes
voilà web à écouter bas vous avez
peut-être sentir oui tout se passe autre
fois alors d'un seul coup je vous
présente les est parti tôt le pactole
papa tu attaques qui est là mais dit
mehdi qui me dit m
et je le sais lola
[Applaudissements]
manix là on dirait mickey aujourd'hui je
suivrai comme ça les betteraves assure
raymond chauffeur livreur
[Applaudissements]
toi tu vas tu es parti qui est là c'est
bernie berniquez banine denis ouais
c'est bon je vois bosser pour nous faire
des sushis chez l'as monaco histoire
mais c'est le sushi mal avec monde en
salle et on s'attaque au tac c'est parti
et toc qui est là pour michel non mais
non mais non c'est qui josh kerr à erwan
et roanne qui font de bonnet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
combattre le coup bravo pour l'applaudir
[Applaudissements]
février au 5 octobre
on a toujours connu fait qu'il y ait
quelques mois là c'est pas possible
ah non non non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que je me trompe si je dis que
vous avez fait espagnol première longue
ça ouais non mais vous pouvez juger ce
que c'est des paroles je pense
d'accord mais attention c'est à dire
comme irwin à jean michel numéro après
numéro un a les crocs tac tox est parti
mais bien deux secondes
là j'ai le feeling à temps mcdaniels a
les attend j'y mets knocked up qui est
là seddik 10 qui dit que le souffle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je
eroglu j'adore non mais oui d'après leur
peur en fait loin de battre tabac etc ok
tu penses du couple hors d'eau daniel et
frédéric paquet la place saint-michel
demandé à rouleaux qu'on attendait une
imitation avec ce que moi tu es que le
vent soufflera et j'en passe
dès que le vent se feront jeu
repartiront cacho madame sur tes genoux
la part d'un artiste
eh bien on l'a fait direct du maire non
mais c'est vrai les deux films sur moi
j'ai un flash à les mecs je réserve tu
te pavillon d'armenonville hsitoire oh
non ça va une fois j'ai dansé pas sur la
pointe des pieds en été on va bien
ensemble
la même de quoi vous avez les mêmes
vannes surtout à les attentions toc toc
qui est là c'est fini
philippe thilly philippe manoeuvre
[Applaudissements]